happy Friday we've made it
okay as you all know the president is
headed to Warsaw on Monday night where
he will meet with Poland's president
Duda and the leaders of Eastern flank
NATO allies to reaffirm the United
States unwavering support for the
security
the security of the alliance he will
also deliver remarks ahead of the
one-year anniversary of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine and joining me today
from the National Security Council is
John Kirby who will preview the trip
I know we were talking about something
else back there but we're not gonna we
were yeah
and now you open it up
it had something to do with my age I
think
um oh thanks Karina I appreciate it
thanks y'all for giving me a chance to
come up here and talk uh on Friday but
um as Karin just mentioned the president
is very much looking forward to his trip
to Warsaw next week which is ahead of
course of the one year anniversary of
Russia's brutal and unprovoked invasion
of Ukraine after he lands on Tuesday
morning he will meet with President Duda
of Poland to discuss our bilateral
cooperation as well as our Collective
efforts to support Ukraine and to
bolster NATO's deterrence
Poland as you know is a close NATO Ally
and has been a critical supporter of
Ukraine over the past year President
Biden will thank president Duda and in
fact the Polish people
for the 3.8 billion dollars in Military
and humanitarian assistance that they
have provided to Ukraine over the past
year and for all the efforts that the
Polish people have done to generously
welcome more than one and a half million
refugees from Ukraine
the two leaders will discuss Poland's
important logistical role as well and
helping the U.S facilitate deliveries of
military and humanitarian assistance to
Ukraine from not only the United States
but from our allies and partners
the president will also have a chance to
thank Poland for how they have hosted
now an increased number of U.S forces
including those that are permanently
stationed and those who were deployed to
Europe as part of our forced posture
adjustment adjustments the ones that we
announced last year following Russia's
Invasion are some ten thousand American
troops in Poland right now most of them
on rotational orders
on Tuesday evening local time President
Biden will deliver remarks in Warsaw on
how the United States has rallied the
world to support the people of Ukraine
and as they defend their freedom and
democracy President Biden will make it
clear that the United States will
continue to stand with Ukraine as you've
heard him say many times for as long as
it takes
and on Wednesday
President Biden will get a chance to
meet with the leaders of the Bucharest
nine that otherwise known as the B9 and
these are largely the the group of
Eastern NATO allies who are basically
and quite frankly literally on the front
lines of our Collective defense right
now and he'll do so to reinfirm the
United States unwavering support for the
security of that Alliance and and
transatlantic Unity
the leaders will discuss our efforts
over the past year to strengthen NATO
which is stronger and now more united
than it was uh than it has ever been and
how each of our Nations will continue to
work together as allies to continue our
unwavering support for Ukraine
now this is an important trip for the
president and it comes at an important
moment
it also follows days of diplomacy at the
Munich security conference where the
vice president the Secretary of State
the senior director here at the NSC for
Europe and many other cabinet members
Administration officials members of
Congress are all meeting with our allies
and partners to discuss our enduring
support for the people of Ukraine as
well as our transatlantic unity and our
Ironclad support for our NATO allies in
light of all the changes to the European
security environment over the last year
and as the president believes that
security environment has changed now it
is changing not will change has changed
in fact vice president Harris is meeting
with foreign leaders including
Chancellor Schultz of Germany president
macron of France tomorrow the vice
president will deliver a keynote address
about our support for Ukraine and the
atrocities that Russian forces continue
to commit against the Ukrainian people
as you all know close coordination with
our allies and partners has been a
priority for President Biden since
taking office and throughout the past
year as we support Ukraine in addition
to his engagements in Poland President
Biden is looking forward to hosting
Chancellor Schultz at the White House on
March 3rd and the president will be
speaking with a number of our allies
next week on the phone including prime
minister sunac of the United Kingdom
president macron of France prime
minister Maloney of Italy as we approach
the one-year Mark since this Invasion we
can proudly say that our support for
Ukraine remains unwavering and our
alliances and our International
Coalition in support of Ukraine remain
stronger than ever with that
we're back to My Age Again
actually I actually had a brief
follow-up on the uh on the balloon
incidents earlier this week okay
um have you seen a story in aviation
week that an Illinois hobby Club feels
like
um their balloon might have been a
candidate for for the balloon shots
any response to that because it's very
particular location and the last set of
data that they got yeah we just can't
confirm uh those reports or or uh uh
what what the remains of that balloon
might actually end up being and that we
haven't recovered it so it's very
difficult so you can get your hands on
something uh to be able to tell and and
because of where it is uh over Lake
Huron I mean we all have to accept the
possibility that we may not be able to
recover it but quick follow-on the
president said yesterday I stood by it
at that that it was out of an abundance
of caution but an anecdote like this
does it make any sort of reconsideration
of perhaps this was an overreaction at
any point over the past week
so I'd ask you to just for a second put
yourself in his shoes
especially certainly in light of the
Chinese Bible and uh what was a very
real
certainly very sizable
um and tangible security threat
surveillance threat to the United States
in the wake of that so uh the military
fine-tunes their radar parameters to see
more and of course they're finding more
when you got these three
and uh they're unidentified they're not
responding to any kind of communication
so we don't know who owns them or what
their purpose is
um you know and they're flying in in
Sovereign U.S airspace
um they're also at altitudes that could
affect the the safety of civilian air
traffic and based on the flight path and
the prevailing winds potentially moving
over sensitive military sites and the
military leaders come to you and they
say
Mr President we don't know what these
are
we're concerned about what they could be
and about where they could be going and
what the purpose might be and we
recommend that you you take these down
uh in the safe you know in the interest
of Safety and Security American people
and out of an abundance of caution the
president acted on that recommendation
because he takes so seriously his
responsibilities to protect this country
our secrets our interests and our people
um so the short answer to your question
is absolutely not you know given the
situation we were in the information
available the recommendation of our
military commanders it was exactly the
right thing to do at exactly the right
time now going forward and you heard the
president talk about this yesterday uh
we're gonna make sure we've got some new
rules in place for how we make decisions
in future circumstances that doesn't
mean and it doesn't mean and you heard
the president say this yesterday it
doesn't mean that there won't be
additional shootdowns if he believes
there's a legitimate threat to our
Safety and Security but it does mean
that we're going to put a new set of
parameters on the decision-making
process going forward but if
it's everything you just said can that
coexist let me rephrase it was there any
feeling of frustration of perhaps this
was a 12 hobby balloon from a group of
kids in Illinois after the fact again
given the information that we had at the
time
uh and the the legitimate concerns about
potential surveillance in the wake of
the Chinese Bible you make decisions
based on the best information that you
have
um and ultimately you have to come down
to some core principles uh when you're
making decisions as commander-in-chief
and of course the most core principle of
all of all is Safety and Security the
American people in our interests so
again I say to you the short answer to
that is no
um and frankly
uh given the circumstances in light of
what happened with this by balloon
wouldn't that be a better outcome if it
turns out that they were in fact
civilian or recreational use or a
weather balloon and therefore benign
which is what the intelligence Community
thinks isn't that a better outcome uh
than to have to to to to think about the
possibility of of Greater threats to our
national security
so Johnny
Embers the
Universe we honestly don't know what
this is more generally speaking what can
you tell Americans about what they
should expect in the future
understanding that these new parameters
are going to be classified if they see
something in the air should there be any
concern that a missile is going to
follow it
um again
we're not going to rule anything out in
or out in terms of how we're going to
treat with additional potential
unidentified aircraft
I thought the president did a terrific
job yesterday of putting this into some
context and making it clear to the
American people that their safety will
always come first that these are likely
we're going to find out that they were
likely of a benign purpose and not a
threat at all so there shouldn't be any
overarching concern by the American
people that that the skies are somehow
full of attack balloons or that they're
that they're at greater risk if anything
you look back at how we dealt with this
again with information that we had that
wasn't complete but yet legitimate
concerns about a threat and and dealing
with that threat safely and efficiently
nobody hurt nobody hurt as these
balloons were taken down and I think
that that should give the American
people a measure of of comforting and
confidence
but the president wants to make sure
that as we go forward we do so smartly
and we do so effectively and that's why
he wants a set of new rules determined
so that we can now deal with these in a
in a perhaps a different way go you know
go in the future well we have you here
what can you tell us about this Isis
raid in Syria
yeah so I think you saw the Central
Command uh put a statement out
um
that last night U.S military and SDF
partner forces conducted a helicopter
raid against the nicest senior leader a
man named Hamza alhamdi and he was
overseeing the group's deadly terrorist
Network in eastern Syria before he was
killed in the raid
as the Pentagon has reported an
explosion during the raid also resulted
in four U.S troops and one of the
working dogs suffering some some
injuries the troops and the working dog
are in stable conditions are being
treated at a U.S military facility at
the U.S medical facility in in Iraq and
I think the Pentagon will have more
information on that okay in the back
thanks for and thanks John thanks John
so first of two questions first will the
American public eventually find out what
these three unidentified objects are
including which companies they belong to
or which specific the nine purposes they
had we would like nothing better but I
can't sit here and promise you that
we'll get to that level of fidelity of
detail a lot of it's going to depend on
an inability to recover these three
objects and just to remind you one's on
sea ice in the north of uh north of
Alaska and Arctic conditions extreme
extremely bad winter weather up there
they have not been able to really Mount
anything on the ice to find them now the
others in the Yukon Territory thick
Wilderness and as as of today I don't
believe the Royal Canadian Canadian
mountain police or their investigative
organizations have been able to get to
it and then the other one fell over Lake
Huron again in very deep water I think
the Canadians have decided that they're
not going to look for it anymore I don't
believe that the United States is has
made a call on that yet so pretty tough
conditions going to be very difficult to
find them let alone once you find that
debris be able to do their forensics to
identify it so I can't promise you that
we'll know definitively one way or the
other question on Presidents by about
this talk with Xi Jinping so as the
administration is trying to ease
tensions The House of the committee on
China is trying to focus on human rights
abuses by the regime by planning hearing
Etc on that topic Will President Biden
bring up human rights issues with Xi
Jinping the president never fails
to bring up human rights concern and
when he met with the president XI in in
Bali he brought it up then and it's not
just with President XI the the president
believes that that you have to lead with
your values particularly in foreign
policy he's never shy about bringing
that up
what's the likelihood that President
Biden meets with uh president zielinski
next week There's no uh meeting uh you
talk about on the trip there's no
meeting with President zielinski
scheduled for the for the trip right now
and uh related to President XI in that
call with uh President Biden as well
have tensions cooled enough uh to wear
the two to two the two leaders could
jump on the phone together right now
there is an open line of communication
um uh and I'm not denying that there
aren't still tensions particularly in
the wake of this Bible Moon we don't
believe it's the appropriate time right
now for secretary blinken to travel to
Beijing
um and and you heard the president that
he will uh he will want to have another
conversation with President XI as you
might expect that he would but uh but we
don't have anything on the schedule
right now and and we'll have to do that
at the time when the president believes
it it's appropriate what's really
important here and I know the question
was about
President Biden and president XI
is that the lines of communication with
the PRC remain open I I recognize that
there are tensions but secretary blinken
still has an open line of communication
with the foreign minister we still have
an embassy in Beijing with a terrific
Ambassador uh Nick Burns and the state
department also can communicate directly
with the prc's embassy Personnel here so
the lines are open
unfortunately the military lines aren't
open and that's really what we would
like to see amended and it was of course
curtailed after speaker Pelosi's trip to
Taiwan
there's no preconditions uh for a call
the president will uh will want to have
a conversation with President XI at the
at the appropriate time
the president's trip to Poland is he
going to be making a stop to jajev or
anywhere other than Warsaw right now the
trip is is going to be in Warsaw
um before the Chinese five balloon
incident led to a fine-tuning of radar
how was the administration tracking
it's flying objects if at all let me go
back and just I want to answer your
first question again I said right now
the triple will be in to Warsaw so I
didn't want to make it sound like I was
alluding to a change to it and your
second question was how are we tracking
these before correct because the reason
why you were able to detect and shoot
down these three objects the president
said yesterday was because
correct yeah
or if anything to track aerial objects
the commander of uh NORAD General van
herk spoke to this uh um last week
um and the way he characterized it was
that they were
uh they were tuned to look for
uh defaulted to look for other types of
threats in our airspace fast moving
lower altitude
more kinetic potential threats such as
ballistic or cruise missiles or uh or
bomber or fighter aircraft that's what
their focus was that they had not they
had not adjusted the as he called it
Gates on the radar the filters to look
for things that were much higher much
slower and a smaller radar cross section
harder to see so as we said the other
day when you adjust for that you're
likely to see more of what you're asking
the radar to look for but it just wasn't
set for that he was focused on other
types of threats more kinetic threats to
our potential kinetic threads in our
airspace so it sounds like you know
yesterday the president said that he
wanted to work to establish a better
inventory of unmanned air
does that mean currently there is no
inventory I wouldn't say there's none
but but I think it's fair to say that he
wants us to focus a little bit more on
this particular issue and and learn more
about what's out there what and what's
up there quite frankly and then how long
do you think it will take to implement
this four-step plan and what will you do
in the meantime is the policy to shoot
them down
before you implement these four things
the president wants no I think you can
imagine that that even though we're
still working on the policy parameters
that uh that we're going to continue to
follow a very deliberate thoughtful
decision-making process here should
there be another track there aren't any
right now
um I can't give you a timeline
specific to the calendar about when will
be done this work but it won't take very
long I think in a matter of days we'll
be able to transmit to Congress the
classified parameters we're still
working out through the interagency
right now and get those uh to to the
hill
within days I think um and then and then
we'll be executing on it so there's not
I don't want to leave you with the
impression that there's going to be some
big old air gap between
him wanting these parameters written and
us being able to uh to execute on them
how long
he weighs uh using some of those
parameters just informally as as we're
looking at the skies again there's no
active tracks right now
um so I I think it'll just be we'll
commit we'll we'll transmit these
parameters within coming days it won't
be very very long and it's not like it's
you know it's it's going to be sent to
be debated on or voted on it's going to
be our parameters parameters divided by
the National Security Council team and
the interagency on how we're going to
deal with this all right so question on
the trip to Poland uh poll show American
support for our support for Ukraine is
softened somewhat uh there's obviously
concerns about House Republicans not
going along with more support for
Ukraine how does the president try to
swear that with his message of support
on the trip and is his audience will you
consider it to be a domestic audience
back home or is this audience uh Russia
and other countries in Eastern Europe
the president well knows that when he
whenever he speaks he's speaking to to
people all around the world as well as
of course the American people but I
think you'll you'll hear messages in the
president's speech that will certainly
resonate with the American people
certainly resonate with our allies and
partners without question resonate with
the Polish people who have done so much
and continue to do so
um and I I would suspect that you'll
you'll hear him messaging Mr Putin as
well as well as the Russian people now I
want to go back to your first question
is it it almost assumes as if
support's gonna Wane or waiver or
dwindle and that's just not how the
president sees it yes there are a small
number of members on Capitol Hill uh in
House Republicans specifically that have
expressed publicly uh there are concerns
about support for Ukraine but if you
talk to the house leadership you won't
hear that and you certainly aren't going
to hear it on the Democratic side and
you don't hear it on in the Senate there
has been terrific bipartisan support
through the entire years think about
what we've done over this year all of it
has been done in the full consultation
and coordination with Congress there's
no such thing as a blank check
we're all doing it together and the
support from uh Congress has really been
extraordinary and the president looks
forward to that support continuing
very much is the president prepared to
send U.S fighter jets to Ukraine what's
it actually got asked this question and
he spoke to it I don't have anything to
add from what the president said I'll
just tell you that we remain in constant
communication with the ukrainians about
what their needs are and those needs
have evolved as the war has evolved and
we'll see where this goes if Poland has
mid-29s at rhapsing air base is the U.S
prepared to facilitate the delivery of
those mig-29s
by the the polls to to transmit their uh
M20 their their mid-29s to uh to Ukraine
we have never dictated to another
partner what they can or can't give or
on what timeline and if if one of our
allies and partners wants to provide
fighter aircraft to president zielinski
that's certainly a sovereign decision
that they have every right to make and
we would welcome that my last follow
from this there's 100 million dollars in
the Appropriations bill in July to train
Ukrainian pilots on U.S aircraft what's
the status of that training are there
there's no training underway uh right
now uh because there's no um there's no
commitment by the United States to
provide fighter aircraft you don't have
to have a fighter aircraft to do the
training no training underway right now
but fighter pot
President Biden street from Poland
can we expect any deliverables during
this trip like a new military package
for Ukraine or a new framework of
support from Ukraine and another one you
just mentioned at the beginning of this
uh press briefing that there are 10 000
U.S troops in Poland why there's no
meeting with the troops on president
President Biden's schedule the president
routinely visits with the men and women
of the military and their families so
does the first lady
um you can't look at a single set of
remarks he ever gives including
yesterday where he doesn't call out the
troops and and how prideful for he is in
them in this particular trip
is a short one and it's going to be
focused on events in Warsaw
uh you know I know you never want to
make it about you when you're up here
but as a veteran myself I can promise
you I never worried ever uh when he was
vice president or certainly as president
about his concern for the welfare of uh
the men and women in uniform and their
families not a single bit and what about
the first question
um I was trying to ignore the first
question I thought that if I was
eloquent on my second answer so I'm not
going to get out of the president I
think you can understand that we have
been consistent in rolling out
additional security assistance packages
Ukraine on a fairly routine and regular
basis and that will continue I'm not
going to speak get ahead of the
president's remarks
with other allies sorry I will say that
that I think you'll hear from the
president in his speech
continued tangible support for Ukraine
going forward I mean
he will talk about the ways in which
we're going to continue to support
Ukraine going forward
so on the balloon question so you've
reached out to allies told them that you
know you believe that these balloons
have been cited over you know dozens of
countries 40 to 50 40 50. have you asked
other countries to take action against
those balloons and have you seen an
increase or decrease
in the sightings and the activity since
this all became public no the purpose
was not to ask them to take action one
way or another these are against
Sovereign decisions that Nations have to
make it was about informing them of the
context of the forensics that we did to
learn more about this program and the
ways in which their countries may have
been overflown in the past
question
zielinski today's book of Munich
security conference and he asked the
West urgently appealed to the west to
provide more bigger heavier weapons more
quickly because everyone fears the
offensive that is is expected so I you
know what do you say to solenski what
will Harris say when she remembers you
can't hardly blame them can you I mean
one year on how many millions
flown into Refuge inside and outside the
country how many soldiers killed how
many towns and cities destroyed how many
hospitals and schools bombed can't blame
president zielinski for wanting more
heavier faster I mean he's a
commander-in-chief in a time of War a
war he didn't ask for and certainly had
no justification for it and we
understand that we also understand the
clock and we know that uh that that time
is critical here particularly the time
in the winter time uh now when the
fighting is not quite uh as widespread
across the country there's a quite a bit
of vicious fighting in uh in an around
back moot
in fact I'd like to talk about that moot
in a second even though he didn't ask
about it
um uh so we're going to try to do what
we can to use this time
to get Mr zielinski as much as possible
as fast as we can so that when the
weather improves and we all have to
assume and expect that the Russians will
want to go back on the offense right now
they're fighting over back move but it's
possible that along that Arc from
Northeast to Southwest that they may
want to renew their offensive operations
that he's ready for it and that if he
chooses to he can go on the offense as
well
um
you didn't ask about Pac move but I I I
want to mention it just uh briefly a
little bit I mean we've talked about
that moot in the past
um no strategic value to the Russians
seems to be an operation almost
exclusively run by Mr progosian in the
Wagner group
more than it is the Russian Ministry of
Defense
um they have made incremental gains in
the round Bach moot over the last few
days and and we certainly can't predict
one way or the other I mean it is
possible that you know they might end up
being successful in back move but it
will prove of no real Worth to them
because it is of no real strategic value
uh the ukrainians will continue to
maintain uh we believe strong defensive
lines across the donbass and we'll be uh
and still are fighting very very hard
for back moot
um but
I do want to say this about the Wagner
group
um and particularly uh with respect to
to Black moot I mean again they're
treating their recruits largely convicts
as basically as cannon fodder throwing
them into a literal meat grinder here uh
in human ways without a second thought
and while fighting in Ukraine we
estimate now
that Wagner has suffered more than 30
000 casualties including approximately
nine thousand killed in action about
half of those who were killed Wagner
folks contractors who were killed were
killed since mid-December
so think about that two and a half
months nine thousand killed as the
fighting about mood is intensified based
on previous intelligence we estimated
that about 90 percent of those killed in
the December fighting alone just in
December were convicts
men that he just plucked out of prisons
and threw on the battlefield with no
training no equipping no organizational
command just throw him into the fight 90
killed were convicts we believe that
Wagner continues to rely heavily on
these convicts in the back move fighting
and that doesn't show any signs of
abating I know you didn't ask that
question but I wanted to get that out
there yeah thank you does it remain the
case that no companies institution or
institutions or other entities have come
forward to the federal government to
claim possible ownership of the three
objects that were shot down as far as I
know it is true that no one has come
forward to claim ownership okay and so
that Illinois group they've not come
forward I'm not aware of any formal
process or official process on behalf of
that group to come forward we've seen
the Press reports yeah have you
identified any possible entities that
could be responsible for not that I'm
aware of no so you have no possible
leads on on where these objects might
have come we don't sir and uh I think
it'll be very difficult to make some
sort of positive identification unless
you can get to the debris and even that
could be a difficult process of debris I
mean there's no way to identify it
without looking at it I mean unless
unless an organization comes forward and
knows definitively that that it was
their property but I mean even that
might be difficult for that entity to
know is the government going to try to
reach out to this Illinois amateur I
know no Outreach to that group we don't
have the debris there's no way to uh
there's no way to positively identify it
thanks
the question regarding the Chinese
balloon can you tell us what's been
determined from the wreckage that was
found
no I can't because we're not done doing
the analyzing
um they uh they did finish their
recovery operations off the Carolina
coast they got uh almost all uh at least
that which was recoverable and it's
quite a bit it's a significant amount
including the payload structure as well
as some of the electronics and the
Optics and all that's now uh at the FBI
laboratory in Quantico they're analyzing
it they're looking at it and we need to
let them do their work in a thoughtful
deliberate way I want to caveat on all
this by saying there may be some things
we will not be able to disclose and I
think you can understand why that is but
we're going to exploit this material as
best we can we learned our lot already
from the bloom by surveilling it while
it was flying over the country we're
going to learn even more We Believe by
getting a look at the guts inside it and
and see how it worked and what it was
capable of what about the information
about the US based on that surveillance
um again we'll we'll have to we'll have
to get inside and do the best we can on
the front physics of it that said we do
not believe that they were able to get
anything additive to what uh already
they were able to get through other
sources because
we could predict its flight path along
that jet stream over the the the
continent
um because it was moving slow uh we were
able to put in place protocols at
sensitive military sites uh in the in
our in in the country particularly in
the midwest uh to limit uh any
collection ability so we don't believe
that uh that the balloon is able to
collect anything uh of great
significance certainly nothing additive
to what the Chinese may have already
been able to do through other means
a year ago in Poland the president said
that Vladimir Putin shouldn't remain in
power we were later told that this
wasn't a call for regime change given
that we're now one year on the war has
dragged on this time is there any change
in the U.S approach do you think
removing Vladimir Putin from power in
Moscow would help bringing into this war
there's no change in our policy with
respect to the the Russian government
um uh what what could end the war is
real simple minute it ain't hard all
he's got to do is take his troops out of
Ukraine they don't belong there anyway
pull them out the war would be over
thank you very much Kareem and thank you
Admiral two questions about this whole
series of military uh shootdowns first
it defies reason that you would have
zero idea what these three objects were
since uh the fighter jets themselves
took video of their sorties will you
release the cockpit videos from those
missions I had to refer you to DOD on on
that James in terms of releasing the
imagery I never said we had zero idea I
said we don't know what they are and so
did the president President also told
you that the intelligence community's
leading explanations at this point are
that they were a benign purpose probably
commercial recreation or scientific
research but uh we we may not be able to
go to a hundred percent certainly on
that unless or until we can get to the
debris and analyze it and as I said
earlier that task alone is going to be
very difficult and I can't predict with
certainty that we're actually going to
be able to get recover the debris but we
never said we had no idea we have we
can't prove definitively the
intelligence Community has helped us try
to do some uh analysis on this and
that's their leading explanation so you
have tried to portray this entire
sequence of events as one in which
Mandarin Chief demonstrated good
judgment at the right time and did the
right things
um the president's critics obviously see
it differently and what they depict is a
commander-in-chief who according to the
Washington Post reporting was able to
track
this Chinese spy balloon from the
Inception of its Mission off of Hainan
Island
all the way to U.S airspace and across
the country and eventually that was shot
down after the Chinese had a good look
at whatever they wanted to see with that
balloon and who then
uh presided over a series of missions in
which millions and millions of dollars
were spent and and missiles were fired
at objects that you now concede most
likely were benign in nature and that
suggests a commander-in-chief who
overreacted after allowing the Chinese
spy balloon to do what it did and then
went trigger happy on a bunch of kites
and and balloons that had no military
threat to them what do you say to that
depiction of the events I've already
I've already reacted to that exact
criticism and the first question of the
briefing I've already reacted to it
nobody no Americans in the air were hurt
no Americans on the air or in the ground
were hurt James
no significant surveillance achieved by
the Chinese Bible
and uh and now we have an opportunity to
learn even more about this program a
program that we started to really study
in Earnest when we came into office
um no apologies here you make the best
decisions you can with the information
you have at the recommendation of the
leaders in the defense department who
are going to have to execute on that
mission the president did exactly that
he put the Safety and Security of the
American people first and he will never
apologize for that no sure thing you
know now knowing everything he knows now
would he take the exact same steps and
shoot off these expensive missiles at
these benign objects we're going to put
some more policy parameters in place
James to govern the way we handle these
going forward you make the best
decisions you can with the information
you have at the recommendation of
military leaders I can't say it anymore
thank you friend um John you said often
actually let me just really clarify one
more thing before I move on to Ukraine
um have we can't imagine anything I said
needs to be clear
have we uh put forward the formal
request to the Chinese for the call with
President okay so there's no formal
request yes yeah no okay uh
president still doesn't want to talk to
president she he will
uh on Ukraine you said often that
Ukraine gets to just
serious effort or is there any effort
from the administration side to look at
Pathways to peace do we have any idea of
what those Pathways to peace might look
like is it even realistic at this point
absent of Putin stopping his aggression
we're working with Mr ozunski on his
10-point proposal I think you're all
familiar with that and he asked if the
United States could devote some of our
team to help his team sort of figure out
how we can best operationalize that
proposal and that works that work is
ongoing okay and um I think part of the
problem with the pathways to peace that
doesn't seem like it's realistic at this
point is you know the issue on who keeps
what territorially that just seems like
it's way off in the future why do you
think it's not realistic right now
I don't know is it do you think that
it's realistic is what is this shown
even a scrap of interest in ending this
war like I said a work it in today no
and what's he doing instead launching
cruise missiles and drones into civilian
infrastructure knocking out the power
knocking off the heat
um uh killing kids
sending kids to camps inside Russia
um
buying drones from from Iran and trying
to buy artillery shells from North Korea
this is not a man who's at all serious
about ending this war and quite frankly
it doesn't it shouldn't have to end
through negotiations now that's likely
the way this will go when President
zielinski is ready for it but he could
end it now just by pulling his troops
out he has shown no indication of being
willing to do that and so there cannot
be a serious peace proposal or
negotiation until the Russians have
shown even a scrap of interest and
actually stopping the murder and the
slaughter of innocent Ukrainian people
and in the meantime
as president zielinski very eloquently
said uh over in Munich there's a need a
real need an urgent need for the the
rest of the global Community to come
together and support him so that his
troops can succeed on the battlefield
and that's what we're going to stay
focused on right now okay so that if and
when he does negotiate he can do it with
a position of strength John one on each
topics we've been talking about right
here first is it relates to the Chinese
spy balloon given the reporting that the
U.S was monitoring or aware of it since
its departure from China much the same
way that they shot it within the 12
miles off the coast of South Carolina
why not make an active decision to shoot
it in the 12 miles or the miles off the
West Coast as well why not shoot it
before it was over U.S Landing without
speaking to the without speaking to the
veracity of this reporting
um
I would
end in the specific nature of our
ability uh to track it uh the north com
Commander NORAD Commander uh General van
Hart has already spoken to this in terms
of why he didn't uh take action at the
time it wasn't that wasn't he speaking
to when it was over the United States
speaking to he got asked specifically
about about approaching Alaska and and
why he didn't take action and he talked
about he talked about no hostile Intent
no hostile threat
um and concern for uh uh for lives and
livelihood on the ground do we have a
domain awareness Gap he has said he has
identified a domain awareness as part of
this review that's taking place so it's
not a review we're simply developing
this efforts we are developing new
policy parameters that are going to be
helping us with the decision-making
process Peter now General van hurk
talked about a domain awareness Gap some
of that Gap has been addressed by
fine-tuning The Radars and making them
more sensitive to things that are high
slow and small
and we'll certainly continue to work
with the defense department as they
begin to move forward they got a new
budget they're working on if there needs
to be more resources of more resources
applied to this particular challenge
then that's certainly a conversation
worth having then lastly about the trip
um in late January the administration
announced dozens of Bradleys would be
sent to Ukraine any update those
obviously needed to be built and the
update on the timetable within which
those will be delivered to Ukraine the I
think you're a little you're gonna
get a little Abrams tanks
that's correct they are I don't know
where they are in the procurement
process that's a better question for the
defense department I'd refer you to
those guys but it's going to be many
months before they can be contractor for
approach built and procured and getting
getting them into Ukrainian hands it's
going to be it's gonna be a while good
thank you
um when the President says he's going to
support Ukraine as long as it takes does
it mean that if president zelensky
decides to launch a battle to retake
Crimea the president would support him
as well and another question can you
confirm that the top Pentagon official
has arrived in Taiwan for a visit on the
first question I'm not going to get into
a hypothetical I'm certainly not going
to hypothesize about potential future
operations that the ukrainians might or
might not conduct that's up to president
zielinski and his team
when President Biden says as long as it
takes he means as long as it takes
he's not trying to be cute by half
there's there's there's no special way
to interpret that he means as long as it
takes hopefully it won't take any longer
than another day or so but I think we
all know that's not the case so when he
says it he means it and I think all you
got to do is look back at the last year
at the at the unprecedented amount of
assistance security assistance alone
forget about the just the financial and
humanitarian systems that the United
States has not only provided but led the
world in providing
um so he stands by that and I can't
confirm your other question he'd have to
talk to my colleagues at the defense
department I don't I don't have detail
on the schedule
um dude are you able to provide update
on whether there are discussions of
other Western leaders coming to Poland
while President Biden is there um there
have been uh Rumblings that Rishi Suna
could come on that's the best award I
can come up with the grumbling what is
that uh Rishi sunak macron could could
come to Poland while the president is
there next week yeah I don't know of any
plans that you'd have to talk to their
offices about their travel as I as I
said he does look forward to meeting
with the B9 the Bucher S9 leader so
there will be leaders from uh the
Eastern flank countries of NATO coming
to Warsaw to meet with the president
with President Duda I do not know about
um I don't know about anybody others I
just wanted
say in my opening statement that he will
reach out to prime minister sunac he
will reach out to the Prime Minister
Maloney of Italy and he'll talk to
president macron and France next week
he's anticipating conversations with
them next week okay thank you and then
does the White House have any sense of
when it will need to go back to Congress
and ask for another uh security
assistance package for Ukraine uh no I
mean uh
again hopefully we won't need to
um but we'll certainly be prepared to we
are still executing in the early phases
of executing on the appropriated funds
we got at the end of the last Congress
which is some 42 I think billion dollars
much of that was devoted to security
assistance and as you can see we've
already started sending packages
um and we believe that this funding will
get us through much of this year and I
just don't have a date certain where I
would tell you we'd have to go back but
obviously if we feel like we need to
back to the president's comments about
as long as it takes we'll do that we'll
do it at the appropriate time uh well in
advance of the expiration of any
existing funds
thank you
well welcome to everyone thank you
um on next week's visit uh are there
plans for President Biden across into
Ukraine no
and then on the balloons the protocols
and the way they've been adjusted now
and how the parameters will be adjusted
in the future does that give the
administration confidence that objects
that are benign in nature won't be shot
down
what I can tell you is
these parameters will help us sharpen
the decision-making process
now that we are looking for more and
finding more and you think then that's
appropriate
but I'd also point you back to what the
president said if he deems something as
a threat he's not going to hesitate so
you're asking me can I promise that
uh that if he were to take that action
that every single thing would turn out
to be exactly what we thought it would
be I can't promise that all I can
promise you is that he will always act
in the best interest of the American
people our national security interests
our our uh the ability to protect our
sensitive military sites and our
nation's secrets that will always come
first and that will always be the
default position that he'll take as he
makes these decisions so that doesn't
rule out that objects you're asking
hypothetical I mean we're not even there
yet all I can tell you is that every
decision he'll make going forward will
certainly be in keeping with these new
parameters but also designed to keep us
safe
have a great weekend
okay I just have a couple things at the
top uh one of them I'll start off with
the turkey Syria and the assistance that
we are providing currently after the
devastating earthquake so the U.S
through usaid is airlifting more than
2.5 million worth of emergency relief
supplies to the people of turkey as part
of the 85 million in assistance we have
pledged to support the people of turkey
and Syria following again the
devastating February 6 earthquakes today
U.S ambassador to Turkey Jeff Flake met
the arrival of the initial delivery of
these supplies at Adana airport while
the supplies were loaded onto trucks for
delivery to affected communities
secretary blinken has also announced
travel to Turkey over the weekend
over the coming days usaid will continue
to transport relief supplies on
approximately 10 flights with more than
1.8 million pounds of supplies of
kitchen sets hygiene kits heavy duty
plastic sheeting for temporary shelters
and high thermal blankets to provide for
hundreds of thousands of people in Syria
we must keep Aid flowing so that the
Syrian people get the help they so
desperately need the decisions earlier
this week to open two additional border
crossings for U.N convoys is welcome but
long overdue and we must ensure that
they cannot be turned off on a whim we
believe that a security Council
resolution codifying the opening of
additional border checkpoints and
Security Council resolution is the best
way to do that and will continue
pressing that forward I also want to um
say a few words about Senator fetterman
and before we before we continue
millions of Americans as you all know go
untreated with depression every day
Senator fetterman did the right thing
and brave thing today today or just this
week by getting the help that he uh
definitely needs so the president is
committed to making sure every American
can get help they need to which is why
he made addressing mental health a
priority from his earliest days as
president his administration has made
unprecedented investments in expanding
access to mental health services
including better incorporating mental
health into the broader Health Care
System securing bipartisan funding to
get more Mental Health Resources to
schools and bolstering the 988 Suicide
Hotline in his State of the Union speech
just last week the president continued
to call for republicans and Democrats to
work together to get this done
as the president and first lady shared
this morning they are thinking about
John Giselle and their entire fetterman
family today and they they are grateful
to senator fetterment for being an
example to this
and briefly and last now I want to say
to all of you yesterday secretary Walsh
announced that he will step down from
his role as labor secretary in the
upcoming weeks as the president said in
his statement about the secretary's
departure secretary Walsh is one tough
Union Chief and his record at the
Department of Labor is a testament to
the power of putting a card-carrying
union member in charge of fighting for
American workers
through the secretary's leadership the
Administration has helped union secure a
historic pay raise for rail workers
continued the fight for paid sick days
for All American workers strengthen
workplace protections and ushered a
historic surge in Union organizing
secretary Walsh's work has made life
better for millions of working Americans
and will serve as a model for all future
labor secretaries who truly value
American working people
we certainly wish secretary well and all
his feet in all his future face-offs and
also puck drops so good luck to you
secretary Walsh and uh and we can start
the briefing so a question on
house over that committee wants to
examine the U.S polo from Afghanistan a
second you know republican-led
investigation into the withdrawal does
the White House plan to cooperate this
investigation how does it feel about it
so I'll say this we have been providing
congress with information on Afghanistan
and the operation for this past year so
don't have anything to add there as you
know the White House Council is very
much focused on the oversight they are
the ones who are answering questions and
dealing with with the letters certainly
we'll take a look at the letter so um I
would I will let them speak to this and
what's the status of the
administration's own terms this is that
ever going to be finished uh so it's uh
don't have any update on the review I
know that's been asked a couple of times
I know that Jake Sullivan came and spoke
to this some time ago our national
security advisor just don't have an
update for you all and once we have
something to share we certainly get an
update on for next week I would have to
I would have to honestly to uh to Jake
Sullivan the National Security Council
team but I know that that came that's
come up a couple times here at the
podium and he's spoken to this I would
just have to go back to them and get
some information for you thank you
regarding Senator fetterman well the
president was at Walter Reed yesterday
did he by any chance sees the senator
there I don't have any uh I don't have
any uh meetings or conversations with
the senator Fairman to speak to at this
time okay and regarding the uh
police officers charged in the death of
Tyree Nichols as you know this is a
community that's been hurting I was
there in Memphis when the video was
released before the funeral we saw the
vice president there uh the people there
want change the policing system does the
White House believe that that can
actually happen and also what's the
sorry what's the White House's reaction
to the officers plating now so I want to
be very mindful because it's an ongoing
case and we are always careful here when
there is a criminal investigation or a
case moving forward but I'm just going
to reiterate what the president has said
before and you know nothing can bring
back Mr Nichols back to his family and
uh and also the Memphis Community he
should be he should be alive today and
uh and sadly his uh his family has to
continue to mourn uh the death of the
death of their of their loved one but we
do believe the president does believe
that Mr and Mrs Wells and uh and also
Tyrese son Mr Nicholson and his whole
entire family deserve a Swift and full
and transparent investigation and that's
what the president believes and that's
what should be called for but I'm not
going to get certainly ahead of an
investigation thank you
um has President Biden spoken to Senator
Veteran's wife 16. I don't have a I
don't have any um any conversation to
read out at this time uh as you know the
president has developed a a very good
close relationship with the fettermans
over the last several months you saw the
president visit Pennsylvania multiple
times uh during the midterm elections
and so they've gotten to know each other
uh I think you know the president and
the first lady put out a very heartfelt
tweet
just lifting up Senator fettleman and
what he has what he has committed to do
for himself and spoken and we really
speak to an issue that millions of
Americans have to deal with every day
and that is incredibly courageous and
brave to do and of course of course we
we wish him a speedy recovery on the
response in Ohio and the trained
derailment with the Hazardous Materials
there's Federal officials on the ground
how long does the administration inspect
for those officials to stay there and
can the White House provide any of
insurance is based on the information
provided to the White House on for the
residents in that town so as you as I
mentioned yesterday and as you all know
this is uh certainly a priority for the
administration the health and the safety
of the community in East Palestine uh
just a couple of things that I want to
say at the top to all of you so we have
mobilized aeroba robust multi-agency
effort to support the people of East
Palestine Ohio EPA is helping the state
test the water and air collect soil
samples and Screen homes the Department
of Transportation is helping get to the
bottom of what exactly happened uh how
what led to the derailment FEMA has been
closely coordinating with the Ohio
Emergency Management agency and federal
Partners the governor said just
yesterday asked for or asked just
yesterday for public health support and
today as we have announced and actually
talked about this yesterday how HHS and
CDC were getting involved and today they
both those both those agencies announced
they are deploying a team of medical
personnel and toxicologists to conduct
Public Health testing and assessment so
we are committed to supporting the
people of Palestine every step of the
way and we are going to be on the ground
helping them as long as it's needed and
and also we're going to hold Norfolk uh
Southern accountable as well and we're
seeing that we're seeing that
accountability uh we're already doing
that process Karina you've got a bunch
of personnel changes happening at the
White House and openings how quickly
excuse me how quickly will you be
announcing nominees for the Labor
Department job and to replace
um you know um the whale brainer that
the fed and then just in that context
there's a report out that Carter Frank
has also
um don't have any uh any Personnel
announcements uh to make at this time I
can say to you that under the department
of of Labor or statue Julie Sue will
serve as an acting secretary which is
common uh but as far as Personnel
announcement I don't have anything to
share at this moment clearly uh filling
the role of uh you know filling those
two roles are are critical and important
and a priority just don't have to share
anything to share at this moment I mean
what are you looking for in a labor
secretary who talked about what you
thought Marty Walsh brought to the job
what are you looking for your economic
team you've raised a lot of concerns
over the last year about corporate
profit taking about just you know
empowering unions kind of supporting
Union unionization drives you are you
looking for a strong labor leader and is
that something that you also would like
to see in the next person to go to the
FED yeah think that's both very good
questions I'm going to leave that to the
president to decide what it is that he's
looking for in those two those two key
critical positions
um you know No One's Gonna No One's
Gonna replace Marty Walsh he was one of
a kind as I just laid out and Incredibly
effective and we are very very thankful
for his service and wish him well so
don't want to don't don't want to say
that's the you know don't want to say
that's what we're going to be looking
for but also that's the for the
president to decide as far as the
president's economic plan or how he sees
the economy moving forward you kind of
see that what he's been able to lay out
these last two years and certainly he
wants to continue to build on that
continue to build on growing the economy
from the bottom up middle out I'm not
going to get into you know the into uh
into too many details there as you know
it's the Federal Reserve so we're always
trying to be really mindful there but as
soon as we have as soon as the president
has decided who's going to be next to
fill those two positions certainly we
will share that
to follow up on that
on that c and kpac have endorsed Julie
Sue to officially become the next labor
secretary in part because quote the
inclusion of an AAA and HPI as a Cabinet
secretary is long overdue
um is she on the president shortlist
so I'm not going to get into uh who's on
the president short list or not uh but I
do want to address uh the fact that we
recognize that it is a priority for the
aapi community and we are uh and we are
proud that through our work with members
of Congress and stakeholders we've made
the most diverse Administration that
ever ever not even in modern uh politics
but ever and so uh so and we believe we
have and it's it's facts uh we believe
we have a historic number of aapi
appointees at the level including three
in cabinet uh all of whom are women
which is Vice President Harris as you
know uh Tai uh as well and so we have a
number of aapi ambassadors like Michelle
Kwan and Chris Liu and it's it's also
about 14 of our appointees identify as
Asian-American native Hawaiian or
Pacific Islanders so this is a a
president that has made a priority to
make sure that he has an Administration
that looks like the country uh and uh
and and that is incredibly diverse and
historically diverse so that is a
commitment that he's going to continue
to make I'm just not going to get ahead
of the president's decision at this time
and then switching topics on a topic
that you brought up
with John Kirby earlier oh when you said
that neither you or uh you the art have
hit your Prime yet does the president
have anything to say about this National
conversation that was sparked after a
claim that was seemingly made in defense
of the president that Nikki Haley is not
in her prime because women hit their
Prime in their 20s 30s and 40s you
know I'm not going to comment directly
to that that is something clearly um
that needs to be addressed by um
I'm gonna say something just give me a
second I have something to say
um
when you look at this president's
Administration and we have talked about
the numbers before
um it is there are more women in his
senior and his senior advisor and his
senior staff role than men and I think
when you think about that you see a
president that truly
um that truly takes pride and takes
uh deep consideration into making sure
and meaningful consideration into making
sure uh there are diverse voices uh
around him and I think that's important
that's important and I and so what I
want to say is just watch his actions
watch what he's done you just asked me
uh about
um uh about uh uh about Julie Sue and I
laid out what the president has done and
having the most diverse Administration
and so I think all you have to do is
look at the numbers look at the people
around him look what he has been able to
do look how he's lift up different
communities including women and I'm just
gonna leave it there it is clearly truly
a priority for him and I'll just leave
it there if I could ask you very quickly
about that raid that took place in
eastern Syria just because John Kirby
didn't get to it has the president been
briefed on the circumstances has had any
conversations with those who were
wounded any more detail about his
relationship to that event so the
president has been brief I don't have
anything more to what uh John Kirby just
laid out he uh we would I would refer
you to the Department of Defense on any
specifics on who's on on who's been
wounded or any uh any details other
details outside of what John Kirby laid
out but don't have anything else sign
off on that raid obviously it was
successful as the dod or the centcom
reported was the president a part of
decision making before it took place
um I again I don't want to get into too
much of uh specifics on this but when it
comes to to situations like this of
course the president is closely involved
can I ask about the first lady who was
supposed to travel to Indiana today she
didn't go because her office says that
she's not feeling very well can you give
us any better it's not covet is she okay
I could say from here that it's not
kovid she is under the weather and uh
and I'll leave it there but is
recuperating I'm not I'm not her doctor
so I'm not going to go into specifics on
what it is but I can say that she is
indeed under the weather it is not covid
and her trip to Indiana That was
supposed to happen today will be
rescheduled at a later date and
okay obviously we hope she gets well
soon the last question is about Rick
Scott as you saw he edited his policy
plan on sunsetting federal programs
after five years to say it now exempts
Social Security and Medicare he says to
the president to Democratic and
Republican leaders that it was never
intended to refer to Social Security and
Medicare and the White House's view does
that end this conversation is the
discussion over this issue done what do
you think
so I thought you would ask this question
so I have a couple of things to say uh
to uh uh to the senator so um I'll first
say this that the president congratulate
Senator uh Scott on joining the post
State of the Union red wave as we have
seen from Republicans acknowledging that
they are in fact been attempting to put
Medicare and Social Security on the
chomping block because that's what they
are actually saying that they were
indeed attempting to do that so for the
past year and we have the facts the past
year he has explained the absence of an
exception by saying if it's worth
keeping we're going to keep it but make
no mistake his true colors are
undeniable and on the record they have
been speaking at both sides of their
mouths here that's what Republicans uh
in the Senate and Congress more broadly
have been doing cutting Medicaid and
Social Security benefits is a
long-standing passion of Senator Scott's
as it for as it is for majority of the
House Republicans who compromise the
Republican study committee and many of
his Senate colleagues ranging from John
thune and to Ron Johnson and so for
example in 1990s senator to Scott
supported fully privatizing Medicare and
let's not forget just weeks ago they all
said and and we're saying that they
wanted to repeal the inflation reduction
act by doing that uh you certainly uh do
it would be one of the biggest cut to
Medicare benefits if you were to do that
and let's not forget the inflation
reduction act actually cuts down the
deficit by 200 billion dollars so we
thank Senator Scott for continuing to
share his heart uh with the world and uh
and we uh you know with that I'll just
leave it there
I'm gonna go to the bathroom right here
okay yes
thank you thank you Corrine um I wanted
to ask about the situation in Ohio uh
one thing you did I don't know has been
mentioned in the list of agencies that
are involved and maybe it's because you
don't have visibility into it is the
Department of Justice is the effort to
hold Norfolk Southern accountable also
extend to potential a criminal liability
or has that been
ruled out based on the fact that doj is
not on the list of agencies as as you
know there is a an investigation
underway but we have done some things to
hold Norfolk Southern accountable just a
couple of things EPA has secured Norfolk
Southern's commitment to cover to cover
all the cleanup costs which is
incredibly important and they're
requiring the railroad to document the
release of hazardous containments there
is also an active as I said
investigation underway once the
investigation is complete the federal
government will use all available and
appropriate authorities to ensure
accountability and prove all safety so
let's get the investigation going see
where it takes us but already we are
making sure that they are being held
into account and the balloons and
objects uh sort of more of a domestic
question does this review or the the
effort to come up with this guidance and
the intelligence regarding future shoot
down protocols is there anything that
extends to the FAA regarding who may be
required to file a flight plan or
anything sort of for the public that
people who may have small aircraft may
need to do going forward it's a very
good question I'm just going to allow
the process to continue and as soon as
we have parameters put put forth we
certainly will share what we're able to
some of that stuff is going to be some
of the information that that will be
provided by this this interagency team
will be classified and we want to make
sure that we protect we'll protect that
and so I'm just going to let the team do
its work and we'll we'll provide more
information as soon as we have it
um thank you so ask you about credit
card debt a New York Federal Reserve
study now shows that America's credit
card debt reached a record level it also
shows that delinquencies are up with
that credit card debt as well as
delinquencies on auto loans is the
president concerned that we're seeing a
crack in the economic Foundation because
of inflation so just two things about
uh about that particular report so the
report does not just measure borrowing
it measures credit card balances
including spending that it's paid off
every month so that's important to note
and also further a credit credit card
balance is relative to take home pay are
lower and then they were pre-pandemic so
those are two things that are important
to take to account and let's not forget
as you know there are other indicators
that we also look at which is really
important the household net worth is 23
above pandemic level 51 percent fewer
Americans are entering bankruptcy than
before the pandemic mortgage Auto and
credit card delinquencies are below
pre-pandemic levels in fact mortgage
delinquencies are near record lows since
the start of the data in 2003 and over
the last few years we've seen credit
card scores threatened an expansion of
credit so we also have to look at the
other indicators and so just wanted to
make sure that and I know you do as well
but want to make sure that we point that
out too so the president doesn't see
weakness then in the overall economy no
if anything I just mentioned where we
are where I mean if you look at past
indicators that I just laid out whether
it's household whether it's mortgage
delinquency we are at levels that we
were pre-pandemic and so I think that
matters and let's not forget we're
talking about the economy moments ago a
lot of that is because of the work that
this president has done on the economy
because of his Economic Policy because
he makes sure that no one is Left Behind
because he came in at a time where the
economy was tanking and was able to turn
that around and grow the economy and so
I think if you're looking at the
indicators and you're seeing levels
pre-pandemic I think that matters and so
that's we're going to look at all the
indicators and make sure we point out
what as you're asking me about this
credit card uh debt record reached
record there are two things that that is
just laid out which it does not measure
and so that's also very important
that's great uh speaking of the economy
uh the Congressional Hispanic caucus
today sent the letters of the president
urging him to
a point a Hispanic American uh to feel
the vacancy left by fed Vice chair Leo
Brainerd is that something he's
considering do we have a timetable yet
as to when he'll uh nominate someone
yeah my answer is going to be similar to
what I gave Andrea which is I just I'm
not going to get ahead of the president
on this at this moment clearly it's an
important vacancy that the president is
going to make a priority to fill but
just not going to get ahead on what the
criteria is going to be who it's going
to be who's on the short list not on the
short list I'm just going to let the
president decide and separately are
there any plans for the president to
visit Ohio in light of the train wreck
so as you know the EPA May administrator
Regan was there he held a press
conference just over 24 hours ago while
he was in East Palestine I just don't
have anything to share about the
president's schedule as you know he'll
be in Poland the beginning of next week
thanks green just a follow up on the
social security stuff as it relates to
the debt ceiling
um recently HHS announced some proposed
rates for Medicare Advantage that would
result in a three billion dollar
reduction to the program I know becera
pushed back on that characterization but
can you explain how does it square with
the president's commitment not to cut
Medicare or are there cost saving
measures in there somehow in the broader
program that you wouldn't characterize
as a cut if it's a cost saving measure I
mean I'm not going to go beyond to what
the secretary Becerra said what he said
is basically where the president is uh I
I want to be very careful here uh
because and as you know the president's
going to put forth his Budget on March
9th and he'll talk about what he thinks
is fiscally responsible and put forth a
budget that's fiscally responsible and
uh and he mentioned this in the State of
the Union he's going to talk about how
he's going to continue to lower the
deficit by two trillion dollars and you
guys will see uh the the specifics of
that of that budget when it comes out
and let's not forget the President also
uh lowered the deficit the first two
years by 1.7 trillion dollars so all of
that is important as the president is
growing the economy and making sure that
no one is Left Behind uh that he's also
lowering the deficit and he's doing that
with these very historic pieces of
legislation that we have seen him uh
sign into law these this past uh two
years but I want to be very clear
um when it comes to when it comes to
protecting Medicare when it comes to
Social Security the president is going
to continue to fight to make sure uh
that those are not being held hostage by
the Republican party to make sure that
we are fighting for programs that taxpay
taxpayers pardon me pay into talking
about veterans we're talking about
seniors so this is something that the
president has been very clear about he
talked about it this week he talked
about it at the state of the union we
need to make sure that those programs
those life-saving programs for many
Americans millions of Americans are not
played with just like what Republicans
are trying to do I just laid out moments
ago how Republicans have been talking
about for years for years how they want
to cut those really Key Programs for our
veterans for our seniors and so the
president again is going to continue to
fight for for those thank you
um earlier today when the White House
release some background information on
Ohio one thing that was said by
officials is that if Norfolk Southern
backed off the commitment to pay for
cleanup then the administration would be
prepared to issue a legally binding of
order to get reimbursed three times the
amount I'm wondering if that was just
like a warning or if there has been an
indication thus far a recent indication
from the company that they could back
off that commitment so I don't have any
indication that they are backing off of
that I just laid out how uh you know
they that EPA is requiring is requiring
or or this the company has committed to
cover all cleanup costs that is
something that EPA has worked very hard
on and is making sure that the company
is doing and from what I understand they
are going to do that and as I said
before there is an investigation
underway and will know more but I don't
have any indication of what you just
laid out it would also it was also said
that a CDC team as you were saying was
being dispatched that they're going to
be on the ground on Monday I'm hoping
you can kind of explain for people just
why why they're only hitting the ground
on my bed so why it's not happening
actually now but also why that didn't
happen this has been going on for a
couple weeks now I want to be very clear
on February 4th we had uh folks on the
ground within hours yeah yeah EPA team
but this matters right this happened on
February 3rd on a 2 A.M on February 4th
hours after the derailment the EPA team
was on the ground so I just want to make
sure that the American people understand
that we did take action and folks were
on the ground uh so uh so um so it is
like multiple Federal agency again we're
on the ground not just the EPA within
the hours it is also important to
remember that it was a serious accident
and so when when these incidents happen
you need to let the emergency response
take place so that is important as well
senior leadership arriving in those
initial days would detract from those
Urgent Response uh response efforts and
when it was a appropriate the EPA
administrator went as you saw him
yesterday and additional agency office
officials as you just mentioned hhscdc
will be visiting soon but the work is
happening we've been on the ground again
since February 4th hours after uh the
derailment happened and and we are
committed we are committed this is the
the federal government is committed to
making sure that the community gets what
it needs and will be there on the ground
for as long as it takes
um Kirby mentioned humanitarian
assistance when he was talking about the
president's trip but you know obviously
the president has talked so much
recently about the U.S security
assistance to Ukraine last year when he
was in Poland he met with refugees that
was a big part of his message there how
much of this trip will be about that
side of it will he meet with refugees
will you add some component like that
for this sure I'm not going to get ahead
of of what we've laid out he'll be in
Warsaw as you know he's going to make a
major a speech and he wanted to do this
ahead of the anniversary as you all know
the anniversary will be a week from
today of Russia's brutal war against
Ukraine I don't have anything else in
any further details to share on that he
mentioned the the Eastern flank right
the uh which is incredibly important to
uh to to be there to show to show our
commitment our commitment to Ukraine but
also our NATO alliance and so that's
what you're going to hear from the
president don't have anything more to
share on any humanitarian Aid or
security assistance clearly there's we
have done a lot over this past year and
there is there continues to be
bipartisan support as you look at that
assistance and we will always share that
with you when we're ready to announce
more but certainly I'm not going to get
ahead of the president from here today
okay I'm gonna take one more time
one more one
[Music]
um 31 uh Democrats joined with
Republicans to vote against revisions to
the D.C crime Bill and now that heads to
the Senate and there could be you know
obviously because the margins are
narrower
the they they could reject those
divisions as well I know this
administration supports the DC statehood
and sovereignty at the same time what
does it make of the debate
over the revisions to the crime Bill and
uh you know just the issues with Public
Safety in the nation's capital
so just because you mentioned the house
Republican I just have to say this on
the record it is yet another clear
example of why as you just mentioned uh
DC deserves statehood that is something
that the president has supported since
his campaign and will continue to do so
as it relates to uh as it relates to the
D.C crime Bill itself look uh the
president has never been clear that we
must do more to reduce crime and save
lives and that's why he's taken those
executive actions that he's done the
last two years he outlined as you all
know the safer safer America plan the
president believes that making our
community safer requires a couple of
things funding the police and promoting
effective prosecution of crimes
affecting families today from gun crimes
to carjackings to fentanyl trafficking
investing in crime prevention including
drug courts mental health substance use
disorder Services human homeless
Services summer jobs and mentoring for
teenagers and young adults and so all of
these things Community violence
interventions and a fairer Criminal Just
system that is something that the
president is going to to continue to
push the third and last thing I'll lay
out is uh taking additional common sense
steps on guns to keep dangerous Firearms
out of dangerous hands including Banning
assault assault weapons ban which is
something that the Pres you heard the
president talk about just last week so
look the president has put forth a plan
a safer a safer Community a safer
America plan to make sure that our
communities are indeed safe he's taken
actions the last two years and he'll
continue to do that and so I'll just
leave it there for now thanks everybody
see you next week see some of you in
Poland